so today's topic this has grown twitch
who made a live stream and they've got
clipped and at one point she talks about
a guy that she'd friendzone for six
months I've got clipped made a clip of
it okay six months don't mean one day I
did I just got a crush on him and I
don't know why and I ended up kissing
him randomly and then he looked at me
when I was trying to make out with them
and he said this is weird
and denied me too which I then went on
to roast him for 20 minutes straight
about how I was gonna go to my
livestream and tell everyone that I
tried to kiss him and he told me this is
weird too where the he then went on to
kiss me and I got my way if I know this
is wrong is because I've been listening
to women tell me what behavior is wrong
or right right I didn't know that the
whole coercion thing was bad I didn't
know about all these terms and
pressuring and gaslighting until women
taught me and so mean
turtle izing these lessons and me like
this is not okay behavior to my surprise
when I saw women who claim to know this
vocabulary and to be against it engage
but wait did you teach me this is not
okay why Ranger I know it's surprising
actually what ends up happening is that
this incident gets discussed on the
podcast I mean even from the clip I saw
I didn't see that is sexual I saw it as
like passion you have to you have to
make a move you don't have to ask oh can
I can I kiss you if you're feeling
something you know you know what oh yeah
yes soon as me and I'm here to call you
out on your [ __ ] I was seeing the
guy for six months and he was my best
friend he'd made moves on me prior he
had I denied his moves wait what do you
mean your wait why would you say you're
seeing the guy over there saying you're
not dating him is you're not saying I
just got out of abuse is how out of it
of households when I was 17 and none of
that changes the fact that you're not
seeing him right you're not dating okay
well all right sorry destiny I had a
best friend who wasn't making this on me
cuz he respected me god forbid to be
fair on this stream destiny did a great
job of presenting his points so shout
out to him for that
I think it's interesting she said some
that since she said I don't think soft
because this guy was you know making
moves on me but he was waiting around
but he respected me enough not to kiss
me and I thought if she said that
because when what she tried to kiss him
and he said no this is weird she
pressured him right by saying I'm gonna
tell everyone on stream and try to shame
him Batman
so you so you love the fact that he
respected you when you didn't want
anything but when he didn't want
anything you shamed him okay all right
then I wasn't seeing him I just had
sleepovers with him every single day and
he was my best friend for over six
months and we would cuddle and play
runescape until 5:00 a.m. together every
morning thank you we appreciate you
sharing all these details I have nothing
to do doesn't matter how much runescape
you played doesn't matter how many times
he said touch my balls
as a matter how many times you guys made
pancakes together it don't matter
it's irrelevant what matters is that you
made in advance he rejected it and you
pressured it that's it everything else
is inconsequential and you can talk to
him about how I pressured him go ahead
these are normal encounters kids have
awkward first kisses yes I think they
had a playful relationship and at 17
she's completely different first to say
it was clear that this guy is just some
sort of like little bit I guess you put
your destiny you are a little [ __ ] so
apparently men who get coerced by women
into doing anything they want to do are
somehow less manly so so people be like
why don't men come forward why don't men
talk about their emotions why don't men
be and then you see stuff like this and
let you know hey she doesn't even
realize it so you know I'm kind of
grateful because you're seeing it in the
flesh but it's just such an interesting
hearing this rhetoric because I might
flip the genders sure the same thing is
it acceptable and you saw the other girl
the other girls like yeah it just
sounded like a little playful
relationship mmm what yeah I just I
don't think these sexual with him it
kiss on what planet is kissing someone
against their will
not sexual so her rhetoric is actually
kids will be kids I was a kid it's
normal hmm yeah I think it's like she's
having her personal experience and we're
kind of parsing words and my focus is
gonna be de-escalation with the human
being who is dealing with this on a huge
platform right who's obviously needed
and then talk about the theoretical
issues that affect men versus women in
this issue and how we treat men
differently in this situation is
impressive like the feminists can get on
here and talk so much about nothing like
this is a topic a sec do you think she'd
be the most poignant one out of the four
and yet here she is babbling on and
she's saying nothing we'll talk about
the theoretical impact this has a and
yes I absolutely agree that this is
being handled poorly but I just think
maybe we don't push people I hate that
when they do that when it's like okay
there's fairly a problem here is the
problem that there is like the often
duty yes it's not okay that guys get my
fine good that's the way let me make 70
cents on the dollar and you have to
understand when you're making less money
it's hard to care about men's problems
[Music]
so these weird limits like this
especially when they're talking about
[ __ ] assault and whether or not they
said salt did someone I'm just saying
like it's this huge platform and you're
putting someone in this very like
uncomfortable area she's defending her
of course
yeah the way she was cornered know she
thinks she's being quarter right now on
the podcast my thing is like yeah she
made these comments and basically what
people are trying to do is they're
trying to recognize that that is
problematic behavior now for all of a
sudden you're trying to defend her her
honor or something no she said some duck
caller on that that's all that matters
all these thing talks about feelings and
pushing her towards the edge listen if
she can't handle it because she's so
fragile she can't handle Chris
maybe she shouldn't coerce people into
kissing her how do you think that person
felt well maybe in this instance it went
well but it's not about the outcome it's
about the process meaning if you drink
and drive nobody cares if you kill 10
people we're still gonna charge you why
because we understand that the action
that you engaged in is separate from the
result what did you say they're not
gonna charge you if you killed 10 people
it's not gonna matter whether you kill
10 people or not is irrelevant to
whether or not getting a turd with drunk
driving yeah but you can have added
charges you're gonna add a charge but
you're always getting a charge for what
you did but we don't base everything off
of the result or the impact well yeah
when you're gonna get judged for drunk
driving the fact that you kill people is
gonna affect your what you're gonna get
but we don't judge everything on the
fact of the result
it's like attempted murder you didn't
kill anybody but are you tempted it
you're still guilty yeah but your
sentence is gonna vary whether there was
some consequences to that or not I don't
think that's a great example the problem
isn't that someone died the problem is
that you try to kill them someone dies
every day yeah we don't charge anybody
right because the result of someone
dying is not the problem the problem is
the action that you took I understand
but if you try to kill someone the
person is not dead but if the person is
gravely injured the injury that you
caused is gonna affect your sentence
yeah I never said it's not gonna affect
it my whole point is the problem is not
the person dying or not the problem is
what you did because if you would have
never tried what you did there would
have never been a result does that make
sense so we can't judge everything based
off of the impact we have to judge it
based off of what you were intending to
do
that's why intent is everything well the
thing that happened is that the judge on
both so I'm just saying it's not a good
example because in the court law the
judge on both on your impact and on the
envies but the most important portion is
the intent what you were trying to do
it's not about the end result does it
impact it of course but it's not the
most important part so if we judge
people based off whether or not the
person afterwards was okay with it
that's irrelevant that doesn't see the
effect the action is wrong the same way
just because you survived a stabbing it
doesn't make it any less bad
right if I try to stab you right now you
try to stab yeah it's not gonna make it
any less bad without live time Yeah
right like of course in the sentencing
portion we have to determine the
punishment to deter people but when
we're talking about I think morality
that's where my frustration is because
her argument is essentially that because
the guys okay with it and they're
friends now
it makes her actions less bet and what
I'm trying to say is that a long
relationship can be based off of sexual
assault a long relationship and a family
can be built off of somebody
non-consenting or someone being underage
it doesn't make the fact that the
inception of the relation we feel my dad
you know I think that's my frustration
because that's the love that she's using
can you imagine a man saying yeah but
we've been dating ever since it doesn't
matter you still kitty I'm thinking
character baby because although that's
like pretty much irrelevant to the
inception of the issue I've got to break
it down no no I get it and listen you
know if it helps the viewers too it also
helps us yeah the reason why I bring
this up is because I had my experience
with that and the girl when after work
she's like yeah but are you mad at me I
said no I'm not mad but I recognized
your hypocrisy like you went against my
consent while I was sleeping
do you know what I'm saying like do you
not see how that's problematic and she
try to justify it to me I'm like it
doesn't matter whether I'm not mad at
you
or I'm not gonna press charges like you
still did something that's done
according to your morals even mine I
understand but you're especially
especially you because you're pushing
and pushing and pushing and you're just
calling everybody like you should be
about this and you're not even about
that life right talking about your
veganism veganism veganism and then you
have in a tree course meal and there's
an M but me that's what gets to me so
I'm hearing this and it's the exact same
kind of logic which is right I don't
care whether it's a man or a woman
thinking it's like it doesn't matter
your action is still wrong you shouldn't
coerce people into gauging with you in
any x pole way you shouldn't be like
yeah I'm not gonna call the uber for you
unless you kiss me right now I'm not
gonna yeah I'm gonna tell all the
friends if you don't give it up that's
wrong even if they later cook it's still
wrong you might not necessarily mean but
how is this gonna be eaten up by chip
it's
somebody else is uncomfortable an issue
I don't care my responsibility is to my
audience it's going to listen to the
message I put out or the thousands of
people listening over another
individuals comfort we killed that with
one sentence you I appreciate you yeah I
was about to dog you on your name
destiny but I mean it is what it is and
that was our destiny this is the truth
sometimes in a discussion with the
prioritize someone's hurt feelings or
how triggered they may be I'm over
talking about what's important and what
message were coming we've seen that
before
yes remember that clip device one yeah
yeah where the girl was trying to talk
about issues yeah and the other girl was
crying like are you good not yo can we
talk about the truth I was about to
learn something out of this out of this
old goofy very confused conversation I
was finally about to learn something and
then and it just seemed like nobody
there was getting in the women weren't
understanding it and I'm just like
ladies I don't think you recognize how
the gender in the situation biases you
what behavior you think is acceptable
here you wouldn't think it was
acceptable if the roles were reversed
and my problem with that is that
oftentimes you hear this rhetoric about
like men be more expressive men go
through these struggles men we hear you
and then when when you hear women who
engage in bad behavior get zero
repercussions I'm like then why would
you expect men to talk about this stuff
how many times girls come to me like
yeah but guys don't get hit that often
I'm like you just think that cuz we
don't complain about it not because
we're more effective at it I'm not being
a joke like right now it's just it is
what it is strengthened with everyone
not that it doesn't count it's still
happening yeah yeah and in that same
token when all this stuff about you know
hashtag I as well happened right a lot
of dudes could understand that you guys
were not being taken seriously regards
to a lot of the claims that we were
bringing forth with people putting their
hands on you or doing all kinds of stuff
we understood that you guys weren't
beliefs a lot of people are sympathetic
that and just interest me that when I
see this stuff a lot of people just
don't get it they can't understand that
men are elected to talk about this stuff
because no one's gonna take her
seriously do that the same thing isn't
it though it is it's just men that are
really just looking at each other like
is that that we can't talk about again
here we go again but right now we're
gonna be feel I creators and men's
rights activists we're at man's right
activist one side feminist it's not even
that we like this just just this week I
was looking nice and that real quick to
the trash I got like some message and it
was like yo you guys we don't even know
if you're right or left you guys just
you can't you don't know which side of
the fence were Man Man Man Man Man you
guys are not you got no it's just that
it's called being neutral try to see the
best of things
we're being nuanced you don't have to
choose the side there's some good in a
lot of aspects let's just see what it is
right I mean you know what's worse the
worst thing you can do on a girl you
said an advocate when you should
navigate for the cause and having toxic
matters the worst thing you can do is
call them out what you see a volcano you
see the whole thing of a volcano whole
bunch of feeling that you feel they
can't really handle that too well and
it's just like yo I'm just letting you
know that you're acting that way but it
is the most satisfying thing to do
I gotta admit there is nothing better
than when someone's self-righteous and
you find out there does stink and you
like smell the roses boo boo they smell
like boom boom boom right it's kind of
like that girl shanti remember we did a
video on her that was really popular
when she was like oh my god yeah stop us
warning yeah you there yeah come to find
out she's the worst one how did she
react she went into hiding she posted
this like victim-blaming apology and I
was just like you too you too that's it
for this video man I don't want to bring
this up to you guys because it made me
chuckle a little bit I don't want to
hear your thoughts do you guys agree or
disagree no so tell us why
[Music]
the friendzone doesn't exist the
friendzone does exist friendzone is not
whenever a guy is being nice to you and
he's waiting for instance no he's just a
guy that's witty from because he's being
nice to you that's not what his friends
on is and when the guys like she put me
in the friend zone no she just said no
to you
that's not what we mean when we mean the
friendzone okay she doesn't owe you
anything because you're nice it's not
we're talking about when we're talking
about the friend zone the friend zone is
when a girl purposely put all her
condition
leave you in the friend zone because
it's convenient okay she leaves you
there and she that's a word I invented
the word word is take advantage of she
prophet eights okay
she takes profits from you being in the
friend zone buddy create profit data
music cuz I prophets know cuz they have
a little bit more trouble I mean she
prophets know she brought the tape you
know I mean there's a little bit more
driver to drop a comment if you like the
word prophecy you profit eights you
profit ated that's just for the added
value of the drama that's it okay
I'm aware that that word doesn't exist I
invented it for the added value of the
drama cuz you have to say it a certain
way
watch watch watch this girl profit
eights cuz she know she's gonna get free
rides she's know she's gonna get there
knowing that the guy walk you just
entertained that you know what I mean
it's like whenever you take a cow okay
you impregnate that's a word right the
guy the cow gets inseminated and after
that you think the baby's out of the cow
but you flash the babies the babies of
the towel in front of the cow to be able
to take some milk from the cow that's
the friendzone more for vegans crazy
pretty but it makes them cuz you flat
you know she's gonna make me because she
sees our babies you just take the milk
and no intention of giving back the
babies no you're gonna make delicious